people love their king  they know I saved the city they know I  won the war  Wars not one it's tempting to see your  enemies as evil but there's good and  evil on both sides in every war ever  fought  they have a choice they can live in my  new world or they can die in their old  one things are a bit tense right now and  don't think I'm talking my way out of  this one  Marlon's preach the ball to roll over  everything and everyone  given the opportunity what do we do to  those who've hurt the ones we love  I want to know which side you're on  tell your father I'm here and tell him  the Lannisters are the only ones who pay  their debt you fight over him like  beasts until you tear and cut I will  burn our house to the ground before I  let that happen  tonight we fight  there's only one hell the one we live in  now  if you want justice you've come to the  wrong place